au coeur de charlevoix 25 européen
débarque pour un séjour d'une semaine
sous les tipis attirés par la publicité
ils viennent vivre comme les autochtones
en 708 nous avons infiltré le groupe
pour observer l'imposteur info chaman
qui mène au stage auquel en attendant
vous m'écoutez et nous découvrons son
acolyte et un autre faux chaman
ils font des affaires d'or avec les
européens nous avons filmé en suisse
lors d'ateliers sur la médecine
autochtones partout pour le retracer et
en france lors de consultations privées
car ce faux chaman se dit nous et en
médecine c'est toujours très
impressionnant de voir des diagnostics
posés avec si peu l'examen clinique
je pense que ce peu réaliste il prescrit
et légalement des produits
potentiellement dangereux
son propre frère marc vip à jamais des
médecins je m'étais ce colloque
les recettes de ces activités vont une
fondation de recherche bidon et lorsque
nous lui posons des questions
il referme la porte sur ses mensonges
[Musique]
le premier lundi ce que l'homme est un
imposteur est survenu à cet événement
contre le fractionnement l'île
d'anticosti d in ou traditionalistes
avaient été évitées et remarques qu'il
agit étrangement pendant les rituels
l'ail est en train de de fermat
fumigation beaucoup de fumée 191 chaise
purifier envahie de fumée chez déjà ça
serait pas ça normalement ce qu'on
demande aux gens de venir s'ils veulent
qu'on s'a pourquoi imposer une filiation
il se fait appeler mouche um
c'est-à-dire grand-père en innu mais son
vrai nom et marcel grondin
à moins qu'ils soient atteints
d'alzheimer avant sinon y'a pas des
connaissances minimales pour un
traditionaliste si toutes des choses
dans maman qui sont sues c'est d'abord
donkey série et pourtant sur sa page
facebook
il se dit héritier de savoir ancestral
pas trois ans j'en prenais deux jours
plusieurs plantes avec mon graveur le
seul enseignant méridien francophones à
partager ses connaissances
traditionnelles
ce sera toujours être surtout
l'impression de lésigny vont chercher à
en savoir plus j'ai vu qu'il y avait une
conférence qui se donnait au cégep de
limoilou api j'étais curieux de taïwan
faisaient qu'ils venaient de m'acheter
yatma communauté et je te revoir un peu
les conférences qui donne sur youtube
j'étais vraiment surpris parce que
et donnait vraiment comme une mauvaise
information d'abord dit que parler la
langue il nous puis à la fin on de
l'entrevue que j'écoutais on entend
parler c'est vraiment pas un mot en août
tu m'as dit owni nous merci se dit tu
n'es ce coup mais tenait jeudi l'once a
pas de bon sens va faire une place c'est
carrément une sur passion c'est la nuit
vraiment là notre nation c'est ce genre
de personnage là une chose que l'on ne
trouvait bizarre aussi avec marcel c'est
que nous qu'on se présente en tant qu il
nous entraînons je suis le fils de mon
oncle et ma tante c'est bon pouvoir
qu'est ce qu'on a comme connexion comme
lien pire et lui s'il est resté flou
s'il est resté vague c'était
guy marcel grondin utilise le patronyme
de guile un nom comme chez les new de
mashteuiatsh
pour en avoir le coeur net nous nous
rendons dans cette communauté au lac
saint jean où nous sommes raconte avoir
vécu son enfance dans cette quête sur
l'homme nous allons parcourir des
milliers de kilomètres sur la route
le coeur du mensonge pierre guille et
journaliste il est aussi photographe et
surtout c'est un deal comme marcel
gilles grondin
ce guide j'aime tout vous regardez cet
homme l avez-vous déjà vu dans la
communauté si non je ne connais c'est un
leader ni dada pourtant il dit venir
d'un aspect yatch police tôt parce que
c'est très simple à comprendre parce que
dans ma famille il ya mon père qui d'une
famille nombreuse mais aussi son père à
lui qui était fils unique puis qui est
le grand-père de toutes les guildes qui
est la communauté donc aucun doute
possible dans ma tête
mais je vous ai toujours
reynaud a nié vous allez voir comme
thierry cauchy donc vous connaissez tous
les guides ici tout en fait
lui vous l'avez jamais rangé à ma vue de
ma vie
donc marcel grande n a pas été élevés
ici mais la majorité des innus de
mashteuiatsh vivent à l'extérieur de la
communauté
même s'ils sont inscrits sur la liste de
bande est ce que le nom de marcel
grondin s'y trouvent nous avons posé la
question aux chefs de la communauté
alors marcel grondin qui utilisent des
fois le patronyme de guilde marcel
gilles grondin se dit en innu de master
yatch est ce que vous le connaissez du
tout aucune somme du rire est-ce qu'elle
était inscrit ici dans la communauté
n'est pas sous les 10 secondes
il n'est pas de match de yatchs d'où lui
vient de savoir ancestral que mon chum
dispense à fort prix surtout en europe
ici dans le village de signy en suisse
il donne un atelier d'initiation
technique de milliers d'amérindiens nos
collègues de la télévision suisse
lyon ont assisté avec une caméra cachée
le coût 500 $ par personne puis le
simple coup d'oeil il détecte une
maladie potentiel à notre collaborateur
après la conférence
il lui recommande des gélules
introuvable en suisse selon nos calculs
motion aurait amassé 13 mille dollars
sans compter la vente de ses produits de
médecine d'autochtones des européens
sont prêts à payer des milliers de
dollars pour le suivre jusqu'en amérique
comme ici dans charlevoix avec les 25
européens qui viennent vivre à
l'ancienne
[Musique]
nous avons envoyé une collaboratrice qui
connaît le monde autochtone filmé en
caméra cachée pendant sept jours les
participants apprennent d'herboristerie
autochtone fabrique un tambour ou un
bâton de la parole participent à des
cérémonies traditionnelles
qui sont ces gens la plupart étaient
français donc il y avait rencontré mon
chou lors de conférences et de salon
en france pour la modique somme de 1700
$ par personne
sans compter les frais de voyage
l'exotisme et tous rendez vous si nos
textes pas ma journée puis parle
d'animaux sauvages une trentaine de
loups de mettre de l'eau quinzaine
d'individus par m apparemment il ya une
trentaine de lots autour du lieu mais il
a beaucoup joué sur la peur des animaux
sauvages qui rôdaient autour c'est un
couteau de cuisine dans sa cellule un
couteau qui est calculé au millimètre
capable d'arriver dans le quart d'heure
c'est un couteau de protection tout pour
épater les enfants surtout
partout on se raconte des mensonges
inutiles qui nous étonne on me
commençâmes à celui j'avais 3 ans
je vais fait au moins douze cette année
mais 74 c'est fou il va fêter ses
cinquante neuf ans j'ai besoin de me
reposer mais j'ai surtout besoin d'eux
m'amuser avec une pizza il dit avoir
quatorze petits-enfants
alors qu'il n'a même pas d'enfant durant
le séjour sous les tipis surprise marcel
grondin présente un autre chaman aigles
bleues aigles bleues de son vrai nom luc
bongo un francophone de la saskatchewan
qui s'est découvert des origines
autochtones lors de rêve il le raconte
lui-même dans ses livres car il n'a pas
été élevée comme un autochtone car je
suis lillois de la collation c'est en
bonne santé
puis tu te développe et maximum
physiquement émotionnellement notamment
est-ce qu'on leur collègue le bleu le
bongo alias aigles bleus qu'est ce que
ça vous dit ce jeune âge j'ai
perfectionné sérieux plusieurs croyaient
lebogo disparu après l'échec de son éco
village il ya dix ans
michel grenier s'est intéressé au projet
à l'époque c'est un homme d'affaires
mais c'est comme musicien qu'il s'était
joint au groupe
parlez-moi de l'écovillage moi ça
m'intéressait parce que nous on voulait
faire une maison que les artistes moi
c'était l'aspect artistique qui
m'intéressait pour des auteurs
compositeurs indépendant lors d'une
réunion
l'ubs bourgault raconte avoir eu une
illumination avec les bleus lui avait un
sens qui nous a dit qu'il y avait eu 30
ans de 5 pages qui allait tout écrit son
sange
qu'est ce qu'il y avait été révélée
c'était tout les règlements de ce soit
les collages et son rêve lui donner
pleins pouvoirs à lui chef spirituel du
sanctuaire du feu sacré une corporation
religieuse
plusieurs membres ont quitté le groupe
avertit par michel grenier cats temps
bien des règlements unilatéraux ces
sources
c'est des symptômes le good
elle le bleu est toujours rectifie
parfois avec motion parfois seul comme
ici en estrie où il a donné des ateliers
à 100 dollars par jour cet automne
visite hu et son enseignement des
cherokee qui vient de l'ouest
et qu'est-ce qu'il est d'après vous ce
cas avec motion il prépare un voyage en
mongolie à la rencontre de chaman
mais ne cherchez plus d'informations
elle a disparu depuis que nous posons
des questions dans un instant notre
collègue anne panassac tentent de parler
nous avec marcel grondin séparation de
maternelle c'est une biche et même là
quand même j'ai aucune pour la première
fois ce soir j'ai fait l'un des plus
ancien rituel de notre nation c'est un
rituel de brigil marcel grondin alias
onze hommes s'est déjà dit chaman
aujourd'hui il s'annonce comme en
médecine
il prenait soin de chaque personne qui
avait un petit bobo les enfants se sont
blessés
des crèmes ces crèmes à lui apparemment
illimitées les pansements la caméra
cachée à charlevoix a saisi images
dérangeantes mais qu'est ce qu'il fait
le garçon avait mal au cou apparemment m
me faisais je ne sais pas quoi une
manipulation directe n'évolue que notre
collaboratrice nous rapporte des propos
étonnants de mouchon sur le pouvoir
d'une herbe sur les avis et c'est vrai
qu'il a testé vraiment fermement
instantanément ça peut arrêter une
triste avc
on la récolte toujours avoir la fois
raison mélanie chine et herboriste à
chicoutimi elle a déjà rencontré marcel
grondin pour lui vendre des herbes pour
la coupe forestière de
sainte-rose-du-nord là je présentais les
plantes et son docteur jean amadou qui
avait eu sa formation l'a 45 herboriste
on aime savoir de quelle école les gens
ont été formés ou d'où viennent leurs
connaissances hélas hélas qui me dit
qu'ils venaient de masse triage et qu'
il y avait appris avec un aîné mais pas
capable de nommer la personne
marcel grondin un cabinet à wendat qu'
une communauté autochtone près de la
ville de québec où il vend ses produits
nous y sommes allés avec une caméra
cachée
bonjour écoutez ma copine que de jolis
gains pour l'anc marcel grondin emmené
mélanie à l'arrière boutique
là où il préparait sa médecine en plein
bric à brac au mépris des normes de
santé canada raconte elle est là c'est
là qu'il m'a dit qu'il faisait avait
concentré liquide à base d'huile puis
les donner en goûte aux gens je dis
ouais mais là c'est parce que lui c'est
dangereux ça fait du botulisme
ça peut être extrêmement dangereux on
n'utilise jamais à l interne
l'huile de plantes m'a serré mais
vivendi des produits en ce moment non
non non moi je voulais pas être associé
à l'huile
non non pas je voulais pour mon nom soit
associé à lui puis de toute façon
comment il aurait pu m'acheter mes
plantes savais même pas comment les
utiliser vous connaissez des plantes
qu'ils arrêtent des avc non non j'en
connais pas nous non non
personne ne connaît cette plante aux
remarquables propriétés et marcel
grondin continue à vendre des plantes
macérer dans l'huile à gérer comme nous
avons pu le constater sur son site
internet
motion annonce des pommades mais
étrangement disponible qu'en europe
lors de ses voyages il propose aussi des
consultations comme ici dans une maison
privée de petits villages français à
l'abri des regards
nous y avons envoyé notre collaboratrice
suisse souffre et oui sophy prétexte des
palpitations cardiaques
elle a 26 ans et se dit anxieuse d'un
simple toucher nous sommes détecte
problème hormonal pour expliquer ses
palpitations est désormais complète mais
comme je venais sort il lui prescrit une
pommade contenant de la progestérone une
hormone a rien à voir avec la médecine
autochtone et aussi des gouttes de son
cru
sylvain le bras droit de mme ou schumann
europe s'occupe des ventes se fie à
dépenser 210 $ pour quelques minutes de
consultation et les médicaments à une
vingtaine de clients par jour
cela rapporte
l'équipe de suisse a montré mouches
mâles oeuvre à deux médecins
on ne donne pas des poudres de
perlimpinpin à n'importe qui qui se
plaint de n'importe quoi il faut d'abord
qu'on est quand même un diagnostic posé
clair et précis nous on ne peut pas
faire ce genre de diagnostic en cinq
minutes
il est illégal de vendre cette pommade
en europe la progestérone appliquée en
voie cutanée et très peu absorbé donc
probablement qu'elle n'a aucun effet
mais si elle devait être absorbées à
petites doses elle pourrait entraîner
des troubles du cycle ou de la fertilité
de retour au québec nous voulons
comprendre ce qu'ils dînent temps les
innu pour lézignan le terme de mouches
home est un titre respectueux a mérité
et s'il ya un moucheron mamache de
yatchs c'est bien que l'on boive un
l'orignal pour nous c'est la belle nous
sommes nourris qui nous aurait battus
qui nous ont soigné lui aussi reçoit des
touristes curieux des autochtones
mais rien à voir avec ce que font marcel
grondin et le bourg de ont maudit de cap
black était le préféré parce que vous ne
recevez aujourd'hui beaucoup nous
affirme un rapport non ils veulent
offrir
oui avatar fin de la tumeur est ce que
vous vous dites jamais nous n'aurons
médecine ont commencé en moi je me dis
porter d'objets sacrés on ne la
connaissant des objets sacrés et puis
comme le mot schaming sa vie la sibérie
les autochtones qui sont là bas
l'ue salué de l'eau sale boulot chammam
mais même les anciens là qui ont 80 90 s
d it et jeté un chat non non et c
utilise en médecin en médecin en france
à nous on va sûrement du porteur donc
porter d'objets sacrés qui ne sont pas à
partager avec des non initiés à ce que
ça se fait soit de faire fumer la pipe
aux européennes bord
je fais pas je n'aimerai jamais ressorti
mes objets sacrés avec lui à non non
jamais moi je fais un survol la
spiritualité
il boite de vie tradition culture à
lemont grand pages parle de mon père je
parle de ma communauté
tout ça mais pas son nom fabrique bâton
de parole non non cette semaine on va
construire en passant de la parole en se
battant de la parole dans les
communautés open air de chien
même chez les anciens le terme chaman
n'était pas utilisé pour désigner ceux
qui avaient le pouvoir entrer en contact
avec le monde est visible ces derniers
nomades comme on le voit ici dans les
documentaires du cinéaste arthur lamothe
utiliser les rêves
le tambour la sq est plus ou moins six
des rites pour assurer de bonnes chasse
et donc la survie du groupe
s'irrite ont été interdit par l'église
catholique et leur transmission a aussi
été arrêté par les pensionnats fois à
présent à présent nous aujourd'hui
certains de ces hommes ou femmes brisées
par le pensionnat se réapproprient la
spiritualité les rites la médecine
traditionnelle aucun n'ose revendiquer
un titre que marcel grondin porto comme
un panache pourraient très humble dans
la vie nous on est juste important
on n'est pas rien de tout seul des
chemins des bêtes semnon
[Musique]
nous reprenons la route cette fois vers
pc mythes sur la côte nord
c'est ici que la dénonciation de marcel
grondin a pris naissance
marc combat caen menait la fameuse
cérémonie contre le fractionnement l'île
d'anticosti où marcel grondin comportait
étrangement la journée d'après en venant
chez nous je fête mes proches et cela
que je juge qu' il y organiser des facs
manille où il enseignait à la
spiritualité dans ce temps là moi je
voyais c'était 500 $ pour participer à
deux jours date est venu où il est haut
niveau c'est déjà quelqu'un qui
profitent de l'occasion disons pour son
lift et soeurs pour se faire d'argent
c'est vrai succès comme ce mois et cela
choque profondément les i nous demander
de l'argent et sacrilège
je pense que ce qu'on fait première
avancée et déjà des personnes qui sont
dans le doute de leur vie de ce qu'ils
vont où ils vont où il dirige je pensais
pas le moment de servir de cette
occasion là pour faire des profits et de
l'argent j'aimerais ça vous montrer
quelques images des aigles bleus
s'ensuit japonais font ça
c'est bien mais est ce que ça vous fait
de sens chez les zoulous
j'ai toujours pendante à la personne se
cache comme ça ça me dit rien c'qui nous
[Musique]
vous allez voir c'est mal âge c'est
c'est là qu'on fait des méthodes
attentes de sudation puis je vous
invitais dans la tradition autochtone
médecine et spiritualité se rejoignent
la tente de sudation aux médailles
tiens la fois d'église et d'hôpital
c'est un lieu de ressourcement
s'il ya beaucoup de prières pour
beaucoup de gays peuvent pas de guérison
dans 13 d'entre elles ont fait beaucoup
dans après du fait que les personnes qui
est qui qui repartent eux se sentent
bien moi quand j'ai demandé à être idée
j'ai jamais pays est tendu m
une personne du mot tendue même et je
pense qu'il faut que ça soit demain nous
on ne souffrira pas de programmation on
continue à souffrir de diverses de
diverses degré et lui se sert de cette
souffrance pour pouvoir abuser de gens
qui sont sont en quête de guérison puis
qui ont besoin d'être ce combat puis
vraiment méprisant ce qui s'écrit
avec ma collègue de la télévision suisse
nous décidons d'aller à la rencontre de
marcel grondin à paris car il refuse
nous demande d'entrevue jeu laborde en
innu en lui demandant comment il va tu
as les cheveux ni ses années juniors
tandis qu'ont été versées mais il
confond avec merci alors je me dis
qu'ils ne partent pas ligne nous aimons
et pourtant dans ces vidéos il disait
parler insee pas votre international on
m'interroge pas pu m'apprendre qu'il ne
parle pas sa langue maternelle
pour le reste marcel grondin persiste et
signe nous était nous de 11 de naissance
vous avez quel âge
chassées hors jeu
et toi
la saga l'âge de 74 ans 74 ans marcel
gronder prétend que tout ce qu'il fait
c'est pour les enfants autochtones
je donne des sommes d'argent fait nommer
la cinquième fois on s'assoit pour ça en
vaut le jury j'ai abandonné
une
professeur la paix 5000 10000 dollars de
quoi longtemps pour aider ces jeunes
c'est drôle ce personne en parle c'est
toujours toujours essayé gothard une
professeure de pc mythe a effectivement
reçu cette somme sur son compte
personnel sans reçu ni projet écrit un
projet scolaire dont la direction
d'école ne sait rien après la pause où
va vraiment l'argent recueilli par
marcel grondin pour les enfants
autochtones
[Musique]
les revenus de ses activités vont enfin
fondation de recherche des premières
nations sur son site internet
moncheaux affiche les photos des enfants
que la fondation aurait t d regardez
bien des photos
l'enfant maori est en fait un acteur
australien
brandon walters qui a joué le rôle de
nous là dans le film australia en 2008
avec nicole kidman la photo de l'enfant
brésilien qui est en fait le goyen
produire du new york times et a été
utilisé de multiples fois sur le web
alors où va l'argent de la fondation
nous avons parlé à une administratrice
de la fondation qui avoue qu'il n'y a
pas eu de rencontre du ca depuis plus de
deux ans une autre ne savaient pas
quelles en étaient membres alors qu'ils
surveillent
de plus le site annonce que les dons à
la fondation sont déductibles d'impôt
c'est faux elle n'a pas le droit
d'émettre des reçus de charité ou de
l'oppression culturelle madame existe
partout mais c'est comme mon corps si
marcel grondin n'est pas un et nous de
mashteuiatsh qu'il ne parle pas la
langue
qui est l'homme qui se cache derrière
mouchon nous avons retracé les frères de
marcel à québec
jean-marie accepte de nous parler de la
famille grondin joseph françois perrault
ça c'est seulement trois cas vous êtes
allé là on est allé le mois plus tard
seul mais il dit qui est allé au
pensionnat pointe bleue
les ballons pensionnaires je mets tout
passer notre vie et pour conduire était
pieds de québec
que j'ai l'air est ce que c'est une innu
non une autochtone non il n'y a pas de
docteur honte et un autochtone super bon
un arrière grand-père donc
quand vous êtes en train de me dire que
la famille grondin c'est une famille de
saint sacrement québec bois ont
plusieurs jours bla bla et puis je
touche le plus blanc c'est la soeur de
ma mère la dernière qui vivent ça c'est
marcel j'imagine ça prévient communion
la façon qui est habillé donc marcel
grondin mans sur ses origines et ses
mensonges de date pas d'hier
dans une autre vie il se disait
psychologues diplômés de harvard
nous l'avons appris en rencontrant cette
femme qui a porté plainte contre lui
pour fraude
ça se passait la vérifier elle souhaite
conserver l'anonymat pour protéger ses
enfants marcel grondin le psychologue
menait des activités top secret
il se disait aussi engagée par le
gouvernement mais de façon très secrète
pour interviewer il se disait
psychologue qui interviewait les
personnes qui étaient arrêtés pour ni
psychologue ni psychothérapeute mais
fraudeurs oui un jour ma recette
grondait va détourner les économies
qu'elle lui a confié au bout de deux
années
je lui ai demandé de me redonner une
partie du moins de cet argent lourd
parce que j'en avais besoin
et puis lors il sortait toujours des
raisons qui étaient très crédible en
marcel grondin a plaidé coupable à deux
chefs d'accusation de fraude pour un
total de quatorze mille dollars et la
rembourser en partie
mais que peuvent faire les autochtones
pour stopper ces gens qui usurpe leur
culture et leur spiritualité pour s'en
mettre plein les poches
on a 1 me au moins un communiqué disant
qu' il faut faire attention lors il ya
des personnes qui s'approprie des
identités pour leurs propres fins pour
leur propre bénéfice et ça entraîne des
situations de frauduleuses de la part de
celui du genre qu'est ce que vous pouvez
faire pour arrêter marcel grondin désiré
ni de vendre ses produits de faire des
sparages s'est fait des entrevues avec
vous ma chère de votre ado comme à
gauche peut tout vous envoyer ce message
ce colloque comportementaliste c est
madame permet vous au bout veut tous
être canadien de mémoire au canada à son
retour au pays
marcel grondin ne nous parlera plus
le bourreau lui ignore nos demandes
bonjour j'aimerais rencontrer le
bourbourg aide le bleu vend ses parfums
chamanique dans ce commerce abunda qui
où il a son siège social
j'ai laissé des messages téléphoniques
j'ai laissé des messages courts y est
joint de panassac de radio canada
puis il me répond pas
je sais pas comment vous pouvez prendre
ça votre nation vous considère comme
dangereuse c'est assez difficile de
parler quelque chose quand on reste chez
nous assis à rien faire et à bord c'est
ce qu'a laissé je parle des personnes
qui partent en toi
moi j'ai encore respect pour un
autochtone qui s'approprie notre culture
à nos autres tenter pourquoi avoir du
respect pour lui
[Musique]
e
je
[Musique]